today I am going to be reacting to
Advent preach's hit piece on me when you
have a house there's a lot of choice
there's a lot of [__] to do around the
house a lot and she works all day
bringing that paper that's that and then
she goes home and she still got to do
some work it's gonna it's gonna take a
toll and she doesn't feel like it's
separated our work like that she doesn't
she doesn't feel like the the the work
is equally separated at home it's gonna
be a burden it's definitely going to be
a burden and see like this is the thing
a lot of these reaction channels will
try to nitpick and they'll be like well
if she's working the chores are going to
be hard guys marriage is supposed to be
hard um and I've told this story like
many times on my channel so I'm just
gonna tell it again there's a relative
of mine and um this relative was married
for 50 years and um this woman did not
believe in divorce like it it was just
not an option in her book and her
husband actually left the family for
another woman and she she prayed to God
for a solution because that was her
belief she did not believe in marriage
sorry she did not believe in divorce so
her husband
um leaves and the side chick died he
came home and she didn't throw it over
his head she asked where they went wrong
in the marriage and how they could fix
it and that's the thing like a lot of
times people on our generation are so
quick to throw in this in the towel like
people used to have their husbands go to
war is your idea of commitment staying
married until death do is part to
somebody who left you for another person
what fellas
if your wife leaves you for another
woman
and tries to get married with that
person and they're together for a long
time and then the other man dies and she
tried to come back are you a great
husband for waiting but you expect the
woman to do that they would have called
that man a whole ass cuck a simp a simp
they would have called him sneakers
listen just lonely things over here okay
without her man okay it's telling you to
wait Lonely by yourself years
for a husband who not coming home well
what look all dude you have to go home
then you have to click yeah you have to
cook then you have to clean it then you
have to put the kids to bed but do you
hear how spoiled we are do you hear how
spoiled this sounds like people used to
get divorced for real reasons like the
death of a child you know my husband's
mistress and now it's because you're
frustrated over a messy house but after
a couple of weeks it's really fast for
you to be drained you figure yourself
why not drink but that's a choice you
you can allow it to drain you or you
cannot
skip it wrong
he said you're drained that's a choice
you think being physically exhausted is
a choice you think somebody working two
jobs coming home late at night
goes right to bed doesn't cook or do
this you think that's a [__] Choice
hey everybody right now who's struggling
and who's really feeling tired because
you got multiple jobs it's because you
choose to be exhausted you know I've
lived with all different types of people
I swear I always have different
roommates in college um and it really is
a choice at the end of the day all the
time because and I grew up with nine
siblings nine I'm telling you [__] can
be worked out this is coming from a girl
who grew up in a mansion and has Daddy
pay all her bills she's trying to tell
you guys where a physical exhaustion
comes from the one of the most [__]
privileged people in America is telling
you physical exhaustion is in your brain
you're imagining it again I'm not really
attacking like what he's saying it's
more of the mindset behind it the
relationship is I mean I just and for
also for a guy that's big on stats okay
I got this is the stat man because again
number two right then then so I feel
like most opinions will come from lived
Real World Experience second thing is
studies when you're not sure you look at
studies I'm going to read this this is
from CBS news all right does the site of
men doing traditional female chores turn
women off a new study suggests that the
more time men spend on household tasks
the less sex they have
our findings suggests the importance of
socialized gender roles for sexual
frequencies in heterosexual marriage
lead author sarbino corts Junior
researcher at the center for advanced
studies at the Juan March Institute in
Madrid said in press release couples in
which men participate in more household
work typically done by women report
having sex less frequently similarly
couples in which men participate more in
traditionally masculine tasks such as
yard work paying bills and auto
maintenance report higher sexual
frequency this study was published in
the February edition of the American
sociological review
surveyed 4 500 heterosexual married
couples from 1992 to 1994. the average
age for the men was 46 in the women 44.
now now the staff buddies study backs me
up I'm just you know men can improve
their sex lives by doing more household
chores study yes couples who share
chores have more sex here we go a study
published in the Journal of marriage and
family in August has found that cup
among couples who share their chores
more evenly there is more sexual
gratification in fact they say
researchers the only couples reporting
having more sex than their forebearers
did are those who are both getting busy
with the household duties why do chores
change anything here we go the evidence
shows that men do a greater share of
household chores of a share of household
work women's perception of the
relationship fairness and satisfaction
are greater listen anybody who's dated
women and this is why I say she's a
child who has no real life experience
anybody who's been in a relationship
knows bro when you do something for your
girl the girl wants to [__] you way more
simple you go pick her up from a spot
you bring her food when she least expect
it you clean before she even get back
she wants to [__] even more why because
because you made life easier it's the
same thing for a dudes like yo will my
girl make me food you best believe I'm
looking hey you sexy [__] with
that spatula in your hand let's replace
that with some d right I remember one
time my girl I just came she'd already
folded all my clothes that I never even
asked her to do she was staying over the
weekend she's out she folded when I
wasn't even looking
yo best believe I beat that [__] up gave
her another reason to do some laundry
but just slowly things over here
wouldn't know that even though she's a
nerd who says their studies back me up
you have selective hearing you have
selectic reading you look for studies
that back up your claim not looking for
anything else nobody takes One Singular
study
and thinks that's real you have to do
dozens of studies other researchers have
to take your studies and back up that
data and see if it changes based off
location if it's double blind everything
like that reading a single study doesn't
make you smart it doesn't mean you're
right it just means there's evidence
that hey this Theory might be true but
you need to test that theory
this is why I say this girl's a grifter
and an idiot if she doesn't know how to
read studies even though she cites them
often she doesn't know what the [__]
she's talking about she's a goober her
pulling up studies like this in a
disingenuous manner as if she's done her
research she has it you know what she
did she went on Google she went to I'm
right.com
and that's it
we gotta we gotta pass according
homewards a past prime 26 year old who's
not married not dating doesn't know how
to dress doesn't know how to groom
herself talking about she want to run
wife school and teach people how to be
eligible for marriage the [__] don't
know what the [__] she's talking about
and she know how to walk the walk
because I never seen no dude say this
girl's marriageable or they'd want to
this girl is everything she preaches
against
oh hi
yeah
you know summer's coming out and things
are going to be pretty hot for your skin
and you don't want to use anything
that's going to be able to
you know ouch
there's gonna be able to hurt your skin
you want something soft you know what I
mean
come here
that's why PA's Henley has the product
for you yeah you do not want to use some
abrasive stuff on your skin some of your
are degenerate soap from the dishwasher
to wash the nooks and crannies come on
pass on baby
summer's coming if you don't know what
to do with your skin I would suggest you
to use the level one box yeah there's a
bunch of stuff a scrub to get in the
nooks and crannies to get all the little
residue out you know there's a daily
facial wash there's also an AM
moisturizer with SPF 15 no it's SPS 20
for the sun yeah use them promo thinly
use that thing it's really great it's
for your skin and it's soft
and
since the wonderful weather is coming
you do want to be able to use that and I
have a wonderful skin yeah thank you for
that
if you click on the link below you will
not only save 30 off your first box but
you will also receive a gift and get
your skin ready for summer you know
yeah
well that started how about you
for 24 hours you work
you work the rest I don't feel like I'm
rested I feel like I'm always doing
listen to him talk me me me me me me
before the family me first I'm this I'm
that I'm that but what about your kid
what about the children and this is the
problem with a lot of these reaction and
like commentary channels is you know
they look at it with a me perspective
instead of the family first I'm coming
back home and I still gotta work yeah
it's gonna be a pro it's gonna
definitely gonna be a problem and
[__] are gonna be like you know
what I'm gonna get me someone that's
actually your partner like a lot of
times women will keep score but we don't
talk about what the men do it's always
about all we do for them but we a lot of
times women don't even realize how much
men do for us and I'll give you guys an
example okay when I was younger my dad
he worked a lot
um and it was actually really hard for
me when I was younger because he would
go to India for like weeks at a time I
remember there was a time in like my
childhood where I I questioned like you
know if if my dad loved me and I was
like but Mom he's gone or whatever and
she's like
um you just got out of volleyball what
did he do he pulled the car up for you
oh he just took your bags to the car he
he pays for this he pays for that like
and she just she humbled me so hard I
think this is common with women where we
don't see a lot of times like the stuff
that men do for us day to day because we
don't notice it and we just start
counting and keeping score of all the
stuff we do for them instead of looking
at what they do for us
um but again this goes back into the
problem with the cultures it's me me
before the family if your dad was gone
for half a year in India
and came back the [__] home
and the children was dirty and the house
was dirty he would have left that girl
but your mom was doing some [__]
chores your mom was taking care of y'all
and humbling your ass
chores your mom was feeding you but if I
if your dad after going for half the
year in India coming back none of y'all
[__] was fed Nani all was
having cold clean clothes not and the
house was not clean he would have been
like well I gotta do this [__] too while
I'm in India I gotta come back I have a
high I have and the choice would have
killed that [__] marriage but
your mama but your mama was there doing
the thing
big ass burden to someone when they come
back home and they want to commit the
divorce you got that right yeah no they
would ever think that is if you haven't
ever lived with anyone and if you
haven't lived with a significant other
that's the only way you could talk like
that help roommates forget forget a
significant other y'all ever live with
roommates and see this is the thing they
go into personal tax and now they're
trying to insinuate I've never lived
with the guy they're trying to insinuate
I've never had roommates which it's
actually funny because I grew up with
nine siblings nine who who's lived with
more personalities than me
no no no no we're playing no no no no no
way
no no no when
we say roommates he said she said
siblings we say roommates I live with
people I live with we talk about
roommates and we talk about relationship
and your rebuttal is your sisters and
brothers
I
and you imagine that that's the same
thing as living with somebody
killed me I'm not gonna lie yo yo Pearl
is unintended comedy like this girl is
so stupid and confidently stupid that
when she speaks you just be like no way
that she said that is it good to get
divorced over chores is that good for a
society is that
this is what they'll do is they'll say
oh well but but this but that but that
then don't get married that's my
argument why would you get married and
take those vows or how about this
argument if you're gonna get married do
your [__] chores how about that if
you're gonna get married to somebody do
your labor how about that how about
live up to your responsibilities which
are to do your part in a relationship
how about that you're you're celebrating
your stunt who decided to stay with a
man who left her for another woman you
think that's a great thing how about we
encourage men not to leave their wives
for another woman how about that
Courtney like like this is such a
manosphere grift this is such a
man-slanted Griff where it's just like
why would these women quit why wouldn't
these men put in the effort why wouldn't
these women clean up after them [__]
cells in their marriages because we're
Cain you know what I mean this is such a
victim mentality no [__] we're telling
you to take accountability and do your
[__] labor pick up your trash do your
[__] dishes eat your food and then
wash them
watch the chicken before you eat it but
you get what I'm trying to say you know
what I'm trying to say right
like she over there stressed because she
gotta do all the extra [__] and you
sitting there on the couch yeah but he
he could be stressed because he has to
take care of the yard
no way
there's no way she
said she said that she said
that's how you know this business never
done yard work that's how you know I've
done my backyard before that [__] is not
stressful
yo I have a [__]
like that's too much because
I should go back
what is it the barbecue but I got a
board a lot
for what the seventh time this week no I
gotta no it's once every two weeks but
after that I gotta pick some weed up
uh
it's so stupid
all right my girl my girl yard work is a
choice
you don't have to have so many trees you
could hire someone to do it you don't
have to have so many bullshits and it's
cheap it's a it's a it's a choice and
it's cheap to hire someone because you
live in America it's pretty cheap guys
one it's cheap to hire someone from yard
work and two you don't have to do it
that often and three a lot of people
don't have no [__] yards to compare
that to cooking cleaning and managing
household chores for things that are
limited to only some places is really
stupid we always assume that the women
is women are in the right and I just
want to read I just want to read
marriage fouls just just to remember
because again I take you so and so to be
my wife slash husband to have and to
hold from this day forward For Better or
For Worse for richer or for poorer in
sickness and in health to love and to
cherish till death do us part yeah love
and cherish don't forget that part you
wouldn't know where you're not [__] up
live and cherish that dude was not
loving her no more and he lived and she
was like take me back
um get don't forget that part that was
your potato on that that that's that
that's that was you he broke the mouse
but you were like no no no no we here's
the other word love and cherish love and
cherish you cherish somebody who you
don't put an effort in for
how can somebody say they cherish this
business but they never show up
to their shifts
and you say you cherish this business
but I find out you're not doing any of
the work when you're on the shift
is that cherishing somebody marriage is
not just vows it's labor you put in
every day and our point is if you don't
do the labor then you're not actually
holding your wedding vows just being
present doesn't mean you're actually
present you actually have to be engaged
I can say I'm here
no Abba
yo Abba
dude
am I really here have a child
let them try to talk to you and be on
your phone your whole time see if that
child feels seen just because you're
present doesn't mean you're really
[__] there and just because you took
vows doesn't mean you actually upheld
them it ain't enough to sign a [__]
piece of paper [__] you gotta work
every single day
and that's what we're saying people not
doing
I'm not saying the Women's Center truth
or the men's notes on the truth I'm
saying there's plenty of situations
where the relationship is very very
uneven and if you cherish somebody you
would try to make it more even you would
try to put in that effort that mindset
what can they do for me what about what
you can do for them chores
yeah
what can they do for me what they
[__] agree to
you acting like they got into a marriage
and said [__] go get a a seven figure
salary
oh oh he's not doing his part he left no
[__] take care of your [__] the
basics you're a grown-ass person can't
clean or take care of yourself like a
child has some self-respect if you're in
a relationship right and the man earns
More Than a Woman all right so the woman
has chords to do and the man has choice
to do all right paying the bill bringing
the money whatever that's that's his
choice right when it comes back home
whatever mowing the lawn or housework
Choice all right yes do toys as well
even if he earns more you have to come
back and just make sure that some things
are uh this is not I'm gonna fix that
[__] whatever it is and that whatever
what not all right car breaks you have
to make sure that he fixes it right
calling the garage if he's not gonna do
it or he's gonna do it himself because
he's gonna that's his chores if he's
there and even if he earns the money but
he doesn't do nothing it's not gonna
it's not gonna be viable it's gonna last
longer because it brings more more money
but it's not same thing same thing for
the woman the woman has chores to you if
she ends up not doing her chores like
she she earns less he earns more so she
does this and that and whatever in the
third
and she just decided one at one point
not to do them then it's gonna break up
the marriage that's it it's normal for
XYZ reason okay it's just normal things
it's normal right your aunt was doing
her chores as well if she stopped doing
them
it would have been gone
that's it same thing same thing same
thing same thing for your mom same thing
for your mom when your daddy was going
to India so yeah it is I don't even know
what this is really that you're arguing
and what those arguments are but yeah
whatever these channels these channels I
don't think whatever
yeah Hey listen uh let us know what you
guys think about just lonely things in
her comments we want to hear from you
guys let us know in the comments below